Olá como vai meus queridos como vão meus
queridos Vamos iniciar mais uma
live antes de gente começar Carlos kman
Boa noite Elane Marta me deem um
feedback do áudio vocês estão me
escutando
bem caso não estejam me avisem por favor
ão bem-vindos a mais uma live comunidade
fechada do Dr
alandra hoje temos um assunto muito
interessante para discutir é sobre novos
achados e de medicamentos que são
utilizados geralmente para tratamento da
próstata hiperplasia prostática benigna
e foi encontrada uma relação curiosa
desses medicamentos com a redução do
risco de um tipo específico de demência
que é o demência de Corpos ou
corpúsculos de li ou Levi de acordo com
o jeito que você quiser pronunciar Então
vamos entender como certos medicamentos
da classe dos Alfa bloqueadores
podem oferecer uma proteção Inesperada
contra essa
doença então pesquisas recentes
Descobriram que certos medicamentos os
Alfa bloqueadores que são usados para
hpb ou hiperplasia prostática benigna
estão Associados a menor risco de
desenvolver demência por corpos de liwi
Essa é a segunda forma mais comum de
demência
neurodegenerativa justamente porque a
primeira causa é o Alzheimer que todos
vocês conhecem já ouviram falar que
responde aí por 75% Alzheimer e a
demência de corpos de liwi seria aí por
volta de
10% então Esses medicamentos protetores
são usados para próstata são os
bloqueadores Alfa ou Alfa bloqueadores
terazosina doxazosina E
alfuzosina então curiosamente aí
a não tá incluído nessa lista
tansulosina
Então esse estudo revelou que homens
mais velhos que tomam Esses medicamentos
para próstata tem 40% menos Chan De
desenvolver a demência desse tipo de
Corpus de liwi em comparação com aqueles
que tomam
tulos e 37% menos chance do que os que
tomam os inibidores da cinco Alfa
redutase que é o caso da Finasterida e
dutasterida tem feedback da Marta que o
som está bom Adriana Boa noite me diga
se o som está bom Carlos Eliane a mesma
coisa tá me digam se o áudio está
bom então qual que é a importância dessa
descoberta então esses resultados são
interessantes são empolgantes porque
atualmente não existem remédios que
previnam ou tratem a demena com corpos
de li Então se um medicamento existente
pode oferecer algum grau de proteção
contra essa doença é um ótimo sinal uma
ótima notícia e poderia ter o potencial
de reduzir significativamente os efeitos
da doença então o pesquisador Jacob
simin da Universidade aa destacou a
importância desse achado e ressalta o
impacto potencial na saúde
pública se essa relação for confirmada
por estudos maiores então eles já estão
estudando quais seriam os mecanismos
protetores uma das hipóteses é aumento
de ATP no cérebro então nos últimos anos
pesquisadores especularam que melhorar a
atividade metabólica no cérebro pode
reduzir o risco de doenças
neurodegenerativas como é o caso do
Parkinson então estudos anteriores
mostraram
que tanto a terazosina Como a
doxazosina com
alfuzosina ativam a uma enzima chamado
glicerato kinase 1 ou pela sigla
pkg1 isso aumenta a disponibilidade de
adenosina trifosfato o ATP no cérebro
Então esse aumento de ATP poderia
permitir que as células neuronais se
adaptassem melhor o envelhecimento e
evitar a agregação da sinucleína que é
uma
proteína ligada à
degeneração
então traria um efeito
neuroprotetor então para investigar se
Esses medicamentos poderiam ser
neuroprotetores em caso de demência por
corpos de liwi os pesquisadores
conduziram o estudo retrospectivo com
dados de seguros de saúde de homens com
mais de 40 anos que tomavam terazosina
doxazosina ou alfuzosina ou mesmo
tansulosina ou finasterida dutasterida
que são os inibidores da calfa redutase
todos
medicamentos usados para hpb então após
acompanhar os participantes por uma
média de 3 anos o estudo revelou que
somente os homens que tomavam terazosina
doxazosina ou alfuzosina tinham uma taxa
significativamente menor de
desenvolvimento de demência Corpus de
liwi comparado aos que tomavam
tansulosina ou inibidores da 5 Alfa
dutas que a finasterida é
dutasterida Então apesar dos achados
promissores tem algumas limitações
obviamente nesse caso Mulheres foram
excluídas que são medicamentos para hpb
e isso limitou a generalização dos
resultados Além
disso os dados administrativos usados
podem conter erros né que foi um estudo
retrospectivo então isso é um grande
problema desse estudo e as análises não
incluíram dosagem dos
medicamentos apesar disso os resultados
sugerem um efeito neuroprotetor dessas
três três drogas alinhado com a hipótese
de que a ativação da pkg1 aumentaria o
ATP cerebral e
mitigar perdão
a mitigar A neurodegeneração então
concluindo essa pesquisa traz uma nova
esperança paraa prevenção da demência
por corpos de liwi através de
medicamentos já bem conhecidos e antigos
para
hpb embora mais estudos sejam
necessários para confirmar esses achados
esses resultados são promissores e podem
abrir caminho para novas abordagens no
combate a doenças
neurodegenerativas Certo E se tivermos
mais notícias sobre esse assunto nós
vamos discutir com
vocês Carlos k esses três remédios eu
comentei algumas vezes tá já falei umas
quatro vezes pelo menos é alfuzosina dox
e ter azina é o nome dos medicamentos no
Brasil eu acho que você vai achar muito
mais fácil do azina que eu lembro que
tinha
alfuzosina terazosina mas se eu não me
engano saíram do mercado brasileiro mas
eu terei que confirmar tá Ah você quer
que eu escreva Tá bom vamos lá mas isso
aqui é um estudo preliminar
tá is é um estudo
preliminar certo
outra coisa não são todas as demências a
demência de copos de li que não responde
aí nem por 15% das demências tá isso
aqui não falou nada de
Alzheimer colocar na tela aqui
ó são essas três aí hoje a mais famosa
mais usada fora doxazosina é a tulina e
eles não viram efeito protetor da tulina
ok
bem vamos para ti mais feedbacks
aqui Adriana dizendo que o som está bom
Eliane também Eliseu
também obrigado aí viu pelas informações
obrigado Adriana também por ter dado o
feedback próximo
artigo vamos falar sobre uma pesquisa
muito interessante que explora os
efeitos de uma dieta baixa em
carboidratos e alta em gorduras né na
sigla em inglês low carb High fat
lchf para a saúde cardiovascular já vou
adiantar que os resultados foram ruins
para quem comeu uma dieta com mais
gordura e eu vou explicar minha
interpretação desses resultados tá que
eu não acredito que esse pessoal que fez
essa dieta fez do jeito certo então eu
tô trazendo um estudo aqui que vai
contra as minhas próprias opiniões os
meus próprios os achados e as minhas
crenças porque eu acho importante
discutir coisas aqui que
[Música]
sejam mesmo que não seja da
minha opinião a gente pode sempre
aprender alguma coisa com essas
informações Tá eu vou explicar a minha
interpretação porque que eu acho que
esse estudo mostrou que a dieta low carb
e High fat foi
ruim para saúde cardiovascular então foi
o estudo de corte prospectivos pesqu
adores investigaram essa dieta lchf low
Car High fat está associada a um risco
aumentado de eventos cardiovasculares
adversos tá na sigla inglês
Mace tá então risco aumentado de eventos
cardiovasculares
adversos mas eram eventos
cardiovasculares adversos maiores tá
então tipo infarto e coisas do
tipo inclui angina estável infarto do
miocárdio
acidente vascular cerebral isquêmico que
apesar de não ser o coração é sistema
arterial doença arterial periférica e
revascularização coronariana E carotídea
esses são os eventos
Ok Além disso foram analisados os níveis
de LDL colesterol Colesterol não
HDL E a polipo proteína
B par para o estudo 1525 pessoas de um
banco de dados chamado uk biobank a
idade média era de 54
anos são 73% de mulheres 95% dessas
brancas então estudo que foi feito aí
muito mais com mulheres brancas do que
qualquer outro tipo de indivíduo né
então não sei porque essa predileção tão
grande com mulher
branca mulher branca seria porque Reino
Unido né mas porque mulher né então
entre esses participantes 305 seguiam
essa dieta lchf low cab High fat ou seja
al terro de gordura aqueles que tomavam
medicamentos para reduzir os lipídios as
gorduras do sangue foram excluídos da
análise ou seja quem tomava estatina
quem tomava e fenofibrato quem tomava
Ciprofibrato tomava outras medicações
foram excluídos Então os pesquisadores
realizaram estudo de cortte prospectiva
são estudos de alto padrão por ser
prospectivo né então você tá
acompanhando o paciente do dia zero
enquanto a pessoa começa com a dieta e
ao longo do tempo ela vai comendo essa
dieta e o acompanhamento foi longo um
acompanhamento médio de 11 anos então
estudo que já tem alguns méritos Aí
prospectivo Tempo longo de
acompanhamento então no início coletaram
amostras de sangue e avaliaram a
ingestão alimentar dos partici Anes
através de um questionário sobre o
consumo de 206 alimentos alimentos
comuns do dia a dia e 32 bebidas nas
últimas 24 horas então Mas aí tem uma
fraqueza no estudo mas também o estudo
de 11 anos não podia ser de outro jeito
né teria que ser questionário mas
questionário sempre tem falha
pessoal então uma dieta
lchf foi definida como a ingestão de
menos de 100 g de carboidrato por dia ou
Não mais do que 25% da energia Total
diária de carboidratos e mais de 45% da
energia diária total de
gorduras dietas que não se enquadravam
nessa definição nesses critérios foram
excluídas elas foram consideradas dietas
padrão tá excluídas do grupo que foi
analisado né não do
estudo os resultados principais
mostraram que o risco de eventos
cardiovasculares foi
118 maior no grupo chf no grupo Alto em
gordura Além disso os níveis de LDL
colesterol Colesterol não HDL e apolipo
proteína B foram mais altos ou seja esse
pessoal também tinha mais as ditas
gorduras
ruins sub análises revelaram que mesmo
excluindo participantes com diabetes o
risco desses eventos
cardiovasculares foram 101% maior no
grupo low carb High fet Então os níveis
de ldr colesterol e aolp proteína B
foram consistentemente mais altos no
grupo
lchf em comparação com o grupo da dieta
que eles não classificavam como High
fat porém aí que tá o pulo do gato
pessoal então eu fiz questão de ir atrás
de detalhes né porque o diabo mora nos
detalhes né qual era o tipo de gorduras
consumidas Esse é o ponto chave desse
estudo a ingestão de proteína de origem
animal foi maior no grupo
lchf tá Eles colocaram aqui do que os
outros grupos a ingestão de ácidos
grassos saturados foi maior também nesse
grupo nesse grupo E além disso a
ingestão de colesterol dietético foi
significativamente maior no grupo
lchf então esses dados sugere que a
dieta lchf era rica em proteínas de
origem animal ácidos grassos saturados e
colesterol dietético que são conhecidos
por elevar LDL colesterol e a proteína B
tá segundo a medicina Ortodoxa né
contribuindo para o risco aumentado
dessas
doenças veja bem Olha o Polo do gato aí
o estudo não mencionou especificamente o
estudo não mencionou o consumo de
alimentos como abacate azeite de oliva
outros óis vegetais naturais o meu
entendimento desse estudo o pesso só
comeu praticamente gordura de
bacon de
torresmo de carne processada e não
utilizou de forma adequada azeite de
oliva abacate
oleaginosas sementes de girassol Semente
de abóbora então meu ponto aqui é o
seguinte será que esse pessoal primeiro
comeu alimentos naturais não comeu
alimento processado Será que essa
gordura saturada que eles estão
colocando como vilão aí não foi porque a
pessoa comeu ela associado a alimentos
industrializados não tá claro nesse
estudo Ok então não houve essa distinção
outra coisa não se perguntou sobre
azeite não se perguntou sobre Abacate
não se perguntou sobre coco não se
perguntou sobre qualquer outro tipo de
gordura
saudável Então se a gente for acreditar
nesse estudo ele sugere que a dieta louc
e High fet poderia aumentar o risco de
eventos cardiovasculares adversos eu não
acredito nisso porque se você faz uma
dieta como eu preconizo a ketoflex que é
muito vegetal colorido muito vegetal
variado que cresce acima do solo baixa
quantidade de carboidrato bastante
quantidade de gorduras saudáveis
especialmente o azeite de
oliva eu duvido que esse resultado vai
acontecer como é que uma dieta que boa
pro cérebro vai ser ruim pro coração
não faz o menor sentido pessoal tá então
acho que foi uma dieta suja que esse
pessoal comeu a única coisa que eles se
prenderam foram na no teor de gordura
Esqueceram de ver o resto Esse foi para
mim o a grande falha desse estudo
tá então aqu eles justificam que o
consumo aumentado de gorduras saturadas
dessa dieta aumentou os teores de LDL
colesterol de po lipoproteína B que é
uma proteína importante apolipoproteína
B é a proteína que tem no LDL colesterol
que carrega a
gordura do fígado para os tecidos Ok
essa
apolipoproteína B ela desempenha um
papel causal no desenvolvimento de
doenças cardiovasculares Mas se você
tiver aí uma gordura que oxidou tá ela
tem que tá
oxidada ele é o principal componente
proteico das lipoproteínas
aterogênicas níveis mais altos de ap
lipoproteína B significa o maior número
de lipoproteínas aterogênicas aumentando
o risco de formação de placas
ateroscleróticas e consequentemente
doenças
cardiovasculares bem primeira coisa aqui
se eu for passar uma dieta low C High
fat para qualquer indivíduo eu vou
monitorar os níveis de elider colesterol
eu vou monitorar a apolipoproteína b Ok
então e vou orientar Qual é a cordura
adequada para ser
consumida
certo então isso aqui para mim é um
estudo de
pegadinha Lembrando aqui
que nem todas as dietas loab High fat
são iguais isso isso aí é uma coisa
muito simplista
fontes de gordura insaturada
especialmente monoinsaturada ou ômega3
tá especialmente gordura que tem no
abacate nozes e castanhas que tem no
azeite Elas têm que ser enfatizadas para
otimizar o risco de doenças
cardiovasculares
se você faz uma dieta loab High fat com
a preocupação de dar gorduras de alta
qualidade de alto nível e também
discretamente hipocalórica você pode
melhorar os níveis de lipídeos no sangue
tá e acontecer em contrário que
aconteceu nesse estudo
aqui bem Vamos às perguntas
Ah tá uma pergunta relacionada ao estudo
que eu tava falando aqui para avaliação
cardiológica melhor avaliar lipoproteína
A ou lipoproteína B então tem uma
confusão aí eu acho que tá
confundindo lipoproteína a com
apolipoproteína 1 tá você avalia as três
coisas a lipoproteína a
apolipoproteína 1 e a lipoproteína b Tá
bom eu sei que é confuso Marta mas é
assim tá se você entendeu me dá um ok aí
se você entendeu ou não deixa eu
localizar o o arquivo das
perguntas arquivo
localizado começar dividir a tela com
vocês
aqui certo Marta Então me deu o
feedback se você entendeu o que eu falei
Ok obrigado pelo feedback bem Pergunta
do Thiago
assisti um vídeo do Dr Fernando Lemos
coloproctologista sobre enema de café
onde ele diz que não funciona e até
mesmo citou alguns riscos e opiniões de
outros médicos segundo ele quando se faz
enema o líquido não chega até o
intestino
delgado esse ponto da pergunta eu não
entendi Tiago por de abos o líquido
teria que chegar até o intestino delgado
Não é esse objetivo né concordo com isso
não chega até o intestino delgado Mas
por que que te queria Por que que teria
que chegar lá né Ou seja no máximo até o
colo o senhor concorda qual seria a sua
opinião primeiro ponto eu não tenho
conflito de interesse com esse
assunto porque não é uma coisa que eu
indique muito que
eu trabalhe especificamente com isso
temos algumas
clínicas que vivem de fazer
hidrocolonterapia E aí os enema de café
enema de chá enema de DS também entra na
jogada então eu não trabalho diretamente
com isso então eu acho que eu tenho uma
boa autoridade para falar sobre isso
para passar para vocês uma visão mais
isenta Então esse conceito aí de que não
chega até o intestino delgado acho que
todo mundo concorda inclusive Quem
promove esse procedimento então eu não
entendi porque ele usou isso como um
argumento
né esse
procedimento de Nema de café é uma
prática que ganhou muita
popularidade nos meios naturopatia ele é
promovido como meio de
detox obviamente não tem muita
literatura em humano sobre essa situação
eu acho que funciona
sim no sentido de promover o detox do
intestino grosso e do fígado porque
quando você faz de café esse material
também é absorvido pelo
sistema da veia porta né porque as veias
hemorroidárias vão drenar na veia porta
Então eu acho que pode sim ajudar na
detoxificação do fígado e aumentar a
produção de
glutationa e pode ser útil para aliviar
a
constipação pode ter problema sim eu
acredito queem alguns casos pode gerar
desequilíbrios eletrolíticos e pode
levar a complicações Como baixa de
potássio hipocalemia e a algumas
situações o café pode até irritar a
mucose intestinal causando
desconforto eu não uso muito isso eu
acho que tem o seu valor sim não acho
que seja uma panaceia Ou seja que
resolve todos os problemas eu acho que
tem que ser usado com parcimônia bem
indicado por médicos que conheçam o
procedimento e tem que ser
supervisionado
também então eu acho uma boa ferramenta
Só não acho que essa maravilha to aí que
muitas pessoas dizem que é
Ok Tiago você está ao vivo se tiver
posso Vamos pro próximo
pergunta dá para aumentar um pouquinho
mais a letra né não foi demais acho que
aqui tá
melhor pergunta do
Eliseu pessoa está ingerindo todos os
dias suplemento probiótico e de repente
suspende o suplemento a quantidade de
bactérias do bem diminui no intestino
quando se ingere uma mistura de quefir
com leite de coco todos os dias depois
de algum tempo suspende essa ingestão É
verdade que a quantidade de bactérias do
intestino do bem não diminui mas
permanece
bem é fato que o efeito dos probióticos
Eliseu é muito mais parabi do que
probiótico tá eu não
creio até pelos estudos que saíram aí
recentemente que esses probióticos vão
de fato colonizar o intestino eles vão
ter muito mais um efeito digamos assim
como remédio tá porque a parede das
bactérias do bem e vão interagir com o
intestino e vão ter um efeito quase que
medicamentoso mesmo que a bactéria
esteja morta então mesmo que aumente a
quantidade de bactérias que essas
bactérias consigam se reproduzir Porque
elas estão vivas isso é um aumento
tempor horário na quantidade de
bactérias Então quando você suspende o
probiótico a população vai cair e tende
a chegar aos níveis basais antes do uso
do
probiótico já a questão do Kefir o
consumo diário de Kefir a população de
bactérias é maior então existe uma
chance muito maior aí de estabelecer uma
população duradora de bactérias
benéficas do
intestino e também porque tem mais
diversidade de espécies no Kef do que no
qualquer probiótico aí que você vai
comprar no
mercado porém o impacto na manutenção
das bactérias benéficas após o suspenção
do Kefir vai depender de vários fatores
incluindo o ambiente intestinal
pré-existente a dieta se a dieta não for
favorável isso
pode Não favorecer o crescimento dessas
bactérias o quefir também se a pessoa é
muito estressada se ela usa muito
antibiótico ou se ela tem contato muito
com agrotóxico ou poluentes
e da natureza e poluentes
orgânicos Isso pode atrapalhar também
essa proliferação dessas bactérias o
Kefir então vários fatores vão
interferir nisso daí
ok O interessante do KF que além dos
probióticos tem também nentes adicionais
do próprio Leite
coco vamos pra próxima
pergunta
Opa Também do Eliseu É verdade que o sal
Marin é mais confiável do que o sal rosa
do
Himalaia já que o sal rosa vem
geralmente do Paquistão e por pode ter
contaminantes por microplástico esse sal
rosa é retirado da montanha que pode ter
resquício de
dinamite isso aqui que você falou Eliseu
achei interessante porque eu nunca tinha
pensado nessa questão da dinamita né e
fui atrás dessa informação sim
alguns fabricantes podem usar
explosivos porém muitas operações também
usam técnicas mais seguras
e controles de qualidade mais
rigorosos porém essa questão deoc
contaminação não é exclusivo do sal rosa
Himalaia não
ok mesmo sal marinho apesar de não ter
que envolver
mineração ele pode ter também
microplásticos o mar tá cheio de
microplásticos pode ter outros
contaminantes pode ter metal pesado do
Mar também então não é uma garantia que
você tá usando sarin que não vai ter
isso
também então o mais importante aqui você
buscar um fornecedor confiável porque
tanto o sal marinho integral quanto o
sal rosa pode ter contaminações
importante considerar origem o
fornecedor os testes de qualidade
realizados certo
Então não é que um sal vai ser sempre
bom e o outro sempre vai ser ruim
eh como amizar preventivamente o dia do
lixo vou explicar a pergunta para quem
come alimentação rigorosamente saudável
durante 29 dias do mês e come porcaria o
dia
inteiro apenas um dia do mês o que se
pode fazer preventivamente para amizar
os prejuízos por exemplo no dia do lixo
com um rodiz de massa e disputo o
campeonato com os amigos para ver quem
come mais para amenizar os possíveis
prejuízos preventivamente falando eu
tomo uma colher de vinagre de maçã antes
do rodiz e uma colher de vinagre de maçã
depois pelo fato de comer grandes
quantidades de massa ou ingiro enzimas
digestivas e betaína
cloreto eh de betaína né qualidade
betaína
você tem alguma dica adicional para
amenizar os prejuízos bem o o conceito
do dia do lixo Eliseu é fazer tudo
errado então se você consegue ser tão
disciplinado a ponto de querer amenizar
os prejuízos da saúde do dia do lixo é
melhor nem ter o dia do lixo esse é me
pensamento tá mas se você quiser ter um
dia do lixo digamos assim menos
lixo Então você pode ter algumas
estratégias por exemplo evitar o consumo
excessivo nos alimentos que você goste
isso que você falou de usar vinagre de
maçã ou enzima digestiva enzima
digestiva não porque na verdade você tá
aumentando até a absorção né dos
carboidratos então eu não vejo como a
enzima digestiva seria interessante
nesse caso agora o vinagre de maçã sem
dúvida é uma uma coisa interessante
outra coisa que poderia utilizar é a
carose a carose é um medicamento que era
utilizado antigamente para diabetes mas
hoje não se usa muito
que você tomaria isso daí e não
absorveria os carboidratos só que dá uma
diarrea lascada então você não ia ter
uma
experiência agradável
nesse dia do
lixo bem outra coisa é beber bastante
água durante o dia do lixo Poderia
ajudar a você eliminar as toxinas que
você está ingerindo e ficar mais ativo
fisicamente também Poderia ajudar a
queimar as calorias extras
se você puder consumir alimentos ricos
em fibra também Poderia ajudar mas aí
seria contra o conceito do dia do lixo e
reduzir também a quantidade de alimentos
processados que você vai ingerir nesse
dia se for possível
também novamente se você não quer ter
nenhum malefício é só não tem o dia do
lixo
né porque o dia do lixo é justamente o
dia para você não se preocupar com essas
coisas o dia de você desencanar então se
você quer encanar com o dia do lixo
icamente não faria muito sentido fazer o
dia do
lixo PR próxima
[Música]
pergunta eleção matinal é sinal de boa
saúde certo certo enquanto o homem
estiver experimentando ereção matinal
todos os dias ele pode ficar
despreocupado que a sua quantidade de
texto L terana está boa mais ou menos né
Mais ou
menos é uma obrigação para o homem
acordar com ereção matinal todos os
dias não entenda como obrigação porque
na verdade é fisiológico né como é que
você vai controlar isso ser fisiológico
Teoricamente não seria uma coisa
voluntária né então a palavra
obrigatória aí não tá bem pregada Porque
se é uma coisa involuntária como vai ser
obrigatória se o homem estiver com
baixíssima frequência de ereção matinal
ele consegue forçar uma ereção tomando
bastante líquido desconheço essa técnica
eu duvido que isso vai funcionar se você
leu isso em algum lugar me diz porque eu
acho muito estranho a pessoa beber água
e pessa bebendo água a
ereção Ah você tá pensando porque vai
ter a vontade de fazer xixi e isso Vai
forçar uma ereção Não é bem assim não
elizu não é bem assim não tá não
concordo com
essa ideia
não eu chocaria os níveis de
testosterona mesmo tendo ereção matinal
tá porque tem gente que tem ereção no
meio da madrugada não se lembra Eliseu
então a ereção não tem que ser na
necessariamente de manhã cedo quando
você acorda às vezes a ereção acontece
no meio da noite você não viu que teve
eleição
certo pô poré a ausencia de ereção
matinal não significa necessariamente
que os níveis de testosterona estão
baixo pode ser outras causas pode ser
estresse o cortisol atrapalha a ação da
testosterona pode ser um sono ruim
também atrapalha a testosterona pode ser
medicamentos ou problemas de saúde
problemas cardíacos por exemplo a pnea
do Sono poderia ser uma
causa então só porque você não acordou
alguns dias sem ereção não não quer
dizer que você não teve ereção no meio
da madrugada tá então tem que tomar
cuidado com
isso então lembrando novamente causas de
falta de ereção matinal baixa
testosterona pode ser uma causa mas
estresse e ansiedade é uma
causa sono ruim sono por exemplo com a
pnea do Sono pode atrapalhar vários
medicamentos podem afetar vocês estão
conseguindo me ouvir com esses [ __ ]
desse cachorro desculpa o palavrão
latindo tão conseguindo me escutar
não desculpa acabei falando um palavrão
aqui eu tô meio irritado então saúde
geral também pessoas TM diabetes pressão
alta problemas
cardiovasculares isso tudo pode
influenciar nas ereções Então não é só
testostero abaixo
vamos pra próxima
aqui sobre a vitamina B12 a injeção de
citoneurin é indicada para suplementação
de B12 pelo que entendi ela não tem um
precip pativo
mecobalamina somente a cobalamina que
não é aconselhada por vários
médicos Então tá bom tá bom pessoal os
doguinhos não estão atrapalhando muito
bem então então vou parar de ser
irritado aqui vou parar de ser
irritado bem o pessoal é o seguinte tá
sulane o citoneurin contém
cianocobalamina que é uma forma
sintética de
B12 Ok então
a citoneurin a cianocobalamina
e a
metilcobalamina é a forma que o
organismo depois vai processar Então
quando você usa cianocobalamina
que é uma forma estável que pra
Indústria Farmacêutica é interessante
porque não estraga facilmente fica
bastante tempo ainda válido a pessoa que
tá totalmente saudável vai conseguir
converter a
Amina emite cobalamina e
adenosilcobalamina que são as formas
biologicamente
ativas só que tem pessoas que tem
mutações de genes tá essas pessoas que
tem mutação no genes tá mthfr tem
mutação também da de gênes da
B12 elas podem ter dificuldade de formar
a forma ativa da
mecobalamina então se você tiver certeza
que a pessoa não tem mutação nenhuma
você pode usar cianocobalamina o
problema é que na prática a gente tem
dificuldade de saber que tem mutação ou
não porque esse exame genéticos custam
em geral R 3.000 não é todo mundo que
pode fazer não é tão raro assim essas
mutações
então você pode usar assim ass não com
balamina e se você passa mal ou se você
não vê eficácia você ou se você fez o
exame genético você usa metic balamina
no lugar
OK agora para doenças neurológicas
existe estudos falando que a
mecobalamina é mais recomendada do que a
cianocobalamina então pessoas por
exemplo que tem doença neurodegenerativa
é melhor você usar
mecobalamina e também situações de
neuropatia periférica diabética outros
tipos de neuropatia também seria mais
recomendado o uso de meoc
balamina vamos paraa
próxima ainda sobre os vídeos do Dr
Fernando Lemos em outro vídeo sobre
protocolo de limpeza do F hígado ele
falou que teve estudos que avaliaram
essas pedras derrubadas na verdade elas
são mistura do óleo de oliva com uma
fruta cítrica como
limão ingeridos durante detox que foram
ácido
oleico ou seja não seriam
cálculos que estavam acumulados mas sim
essa reação entre os produtos ingeridos
no vídeo ele Alerta sobre os riscos de
colangite pancreatite relatado por
pessoas que seguiriam o protocolo
Porém vejo muita gente dizendo que
tiveram bons resultados na sua
opinião além dos riscos o protocolo
realiza um detox realmente ou não isso é
um outro procedimento que eu também não
tenho grandes amores por ele tá já
prescrevi para uns sei lá 10 pacientes
isso geralmente porque o paciente
pediu e eu realmente achei esse estudo
foi um estudo publicado em 2005 na
revista deet que é uma das revistas mais
respeitadas aí no mundo acadêmico então
um estudo relativamente antigo já tem
praticamente 20 anos o título dele é
could disb galston seriam esses cálculos
biliares foi conduzido por pesquisadores
na Nova
Zelândia e eles investigaram o caso de
uma mulher de 40 anos que havia seguido
o regime do detox pato biliar do Dr
Moritz
e o protocolo nesse caso era uma
ingestão de suco de maçã e vegetais até
à 18 horas e consumo de 600 ml de azeite
300 ml de suco de limão ao longo de
várias horas E aí após seguir esse
protocolo a paciente eliminou Aquele
monte de pedras né que o pessoal chama
dessa
forma eram pedras verdes
semissólidas na manhã seguinte Eles
foram analisar as pedras Descobriram que
não possuíam estrutura Cristalina
derretiam em um líquido verde oleoso
após 10 minutos a 40º c não continham
colesterol né que é um constituinte da
cálculo biliar também não tinham
bilirubina ou
cálcio e eram compostos principalmente
de Aços graxos então eles fizeram
experimentos nessas supostas pedras e
concluíram que ela eram na verdade o
resultado da ação das Lip
gástricas sobre os trigliceridos do
azeite produzindo ácidos carboxílicos de
cadeia longa especialmente o ácido leico
então esses ácidos passavam por um
processo de
saponificação formando micelas
insolúveis
de material chamado carboxilato potássio
que também é conhecido como pedra de
sabão então misturou a gordura com a
enzima e gerou um sabão ok foi essa que
é o resumo da
aqui então o estudo ess estudo de 2005
concluiu que os regimes de limpeza do
Moritz são um mito e que as alegações
são enganosas as supostas pedras
expelidas não são cálculos biliares
reais mas sim o resultado da mistura dos
ingredientes ingeridos com os processos
digestivos Então pessoal a minha opinião
eh sobre isso é que eu acho que as
pessoas que comentam que se sentem bem e
eu já vi isso no consultório várias
pessoas que fizeram várias vezes esse
detox e se sentiram bem geralmente são
pessoas constipadas e que realmente a
diarreia provocada pelo
protocolo acaba sendo um detox para
esses pacientes Tá mas eu já ouvi gente
comentando também que não fez diferença
e outras tando que não se sentiam bem
então eu realmente eu não sou fã desse
protocolo apesar de nunca ter visto
essas alegações aí de colangite e
pancreatite tá esse risco aí que ele
fala eu acho que é um pouco exagerado tá
você estão me ouvindo eu acho que teve
algum problema de conexão aqui deixa eu
ver se eu tô conectado no wi-fi aqui ou
no eu vou até desligar o wi-fi
aqui vocês estão me escutando ainda
pessoal tá tudo
bem por favor me dê um que marrar
possível porque eu acho que eu tava
tendo algum problema aqui de
conexão ficou mudo e voltou legal ficou
quanto tempo mudo Eliseu ficou poucos
segundos
ou
ficou mais tempo do que
isso vou esperar vocês responderem você
tá ouvindo Tá bom mas eu fiquei quanto
tempo fora 10 segundos 5
segundos Dá para me dar uma posição
vocês conseguiram pegar o que eu falei
do protocolo do
Moritz do Andreas muritz 8 segundos tá
então foi pouco tempo então né
Legal eu tava comentando que eu não sei
porque que o canal do Fernando Lemos é
tão Popular porque eu acho ele meio
antipático assim no vídeo tá
eh mas aí vocês me dê a posição de vocês
porque ele é muito pelo menos os vídeos
que eu vi dele era bem ortodoxo né e não
era um cara assim muito eh carismático
não vocês podem me dizer porque que
vocês acham que ele faz tanto sucesso né
eu tenho essa dúvida tá porque a pouco o
pouco material que eu vi dele eu não
gostei muito do jeito que ele se
expressa
[Música]
não bem vamos pra próxima pergunta aqui
não tô falando nada contra ele
profissionalmente tá ele pode ser um
excelente col proctologista só tô só
fico curioso porque que ele é tão tem um
canal tão grande sendo assim meio
antipático
né pergunta da
Silvana legal Carlos obrigado pelo
feedback tá o fibrinogênio da minha
sogra de 71 anos está 439 Ferritina 339
mista 17 Gama GT 36 cortisol 11 gente eu
já falei algumas vezes talvez a Silvana
seja nova e ela ainda não entendeu eu
não analiso exame de pacientes tá
genericamente falando uma pessoa com
fibrinogênio alto você pode dar
natoquinase você pode dar picnogenol uma
Ferritina alta você pode fazer sangria
você pode fazer uso de Ferro homeopático
você você pode desinflamar essa pessoa
com a falip
poico com tocotrienois
com nac Tá mas assim eu não estou dando
conduta pra sogra tá da Silvana eu estou
falando de modo genérico tá e não por
favor não façam perguntas desse jeito tá
talvez a Silvana seja a primeira vez que
tenha feito essa pergunta dessa forma e
ela não tá sabendo mas isso tá na
descrição do grupo tá E tá também se se
me engano tá no canal
também ok então essa senhora dona
Silvana sua sogra tem que passar em
consulta para avaliar Porque que a
Ferritina tá alta Porque que a mista tá
alta que pode ser deficiência de
vitaminas do complexo B pode ser
funcionamento ruim do rim pode ser um
monte coisa tá então tem que ser
analisado isso como uma uma forma muito
mais aprofundada
Estela Mares as placas de titânio usadas
no aparelho de hidrogênio molecular não
fazem mal paraa saúde Pois vamos aspirar
e ingerir água eu achei a pergunta muito
boa eu vou fazer o seguinte eu vou
colocar o áudio aqui do Marcelo Nonato
para vocês
escutarem respondendo essa essa pergunta
tá me digam se o áudio dele tá entrando
bem tá se vocês estão entendendo bem o
áudio dele
Então é isso pessoal deu para escutar
bem a a explicação dele
tá então tá bom então vocês não
escutaram o áudio dele né o que ele
basicamente disse o seguinte que existe
um um sensor ali na na membrana de
titânio que ele não deixa o aparelho
funcionar se esver acima de um certo
valor tá E diz que o tit também inerte
ele não reage com
a eu vou eu vou pegar esse áudio e vou
colocar
dentro do grupo
tá fazer assim eu achei que tava saindo
bem o áudio
porque saiu no altofalante então achei
que tava
captando eu ouvi bem aqui o o áudio
vocês não escutaram achei curioso isso
daí Deixa eu ver se eu consigo pegar e
transformar em texto isso
aqui vamos ver aqui
Tá mas eh vocês escutaram a minha
explicação meu resumo que eu fiz não
pronto eu transformei o o o áudio
em em texto
tá e vou jogar lá no grupo mas eu vou
jogar também aqui
tá joguei lá no grupo e vou jogar
aqui não sei nem se vai entrar porque a
quantidade de texto é um pouco
maior cara acho que minha internet tá
com algum problema
bem eu coloquei no grupo eu acho que não
não deu muito certo copiar e colar aqui
não vocês estão me
ouvindo bem temos mais perguntas temos
pergunta da Marilda desculpe-me Doutor
vou tentar explicar melhor as minhas
dúvidas porque recomendado por diversos
médicos que quando se suplementa zinco
como manutenção ele deve ser acompanhado
de cobre porque eles competem entre si
eu já falei isso em duas lives
anteriores muitos
médicos pedem para suplementar Zin com
cobre porque eles competem
si Ok por isso que tem essa questão da
proporção de 10% da do miligramagem do
zinco Ok Geralmente eu passo 20 MG de
zinco para 3 MG de cobre Agora eu só vou
suplementar os dois juntos Quando os
dois estão baixos se o zinco tiver alto
e o cobre baixo eu só vou suplementar
cobre por que que eu vou suplementar
zinco se tá
alto se eu tiver também a situação do
zinco baixo e o cobre alto eu só vou
suplementar zinco se tiver cobre baixo e
Zinco alto eu só vou suplementar cobre
se eu tiver os dois baixos eu vou
suplementar os dois se tiver os dois
altos eu vou vou fazer aquação dos dois
ficou Claro para vocês isso porque eu já
falei isso desse assunto várias
vezes eu não tô entendendo bem porque
que a Marilda não tá
entendendo vocês tinham entendido da
outra vez que eu falei desse assunto
não é uma coisa clara isso que
deficiência de zinco suplementa zinco
deficiência de cobre suplementa cobre os
dois estão baixos suplementa os dois não
é obrigatório
suplementar os dois juntos a não ser que
a pessoa esteja com deficiência dos
dois ou ainda se tá com deficiência de
um mineral e o outro tá no limite
inferior Aí você faz as as duas
suplementações mas eu vejo muitos casos
de pessoas que
tem um desses minerais alto e outro
baixo aí você só vai dar aquele que tá
faltando ficou dúvida sobre isso é
porque a marido geralmente não fica ao
vivo né porque eu já falei desse assunto
várias vezes então não tô entendendo
porque que essa dúvida continua
tá na Live do dia 18
eu sugeri que para suplementar ferro
pode-se usar sulfato gluconato ou
fumarato
ferroso ou ainda polimaltose férrica
qual decisão mais
eficiente desses daí os mais eficientes
é o sulfato ferroso e o fumarato ferroso
tá eles têm alta biodisponibilidade mas
eles têm desvantagens porque eles podem
ter mais efeitos
colaterais no estômago ou no intestino
já a polimaltose
férrica ela tem um biodisponibilidade um
pouquinho menor é frequentemente melhor
tolerada Essa é a vantagem
dela certo então ela vai absorver um
pouquinho menos mas vai ser melhor
tolerada então se você tem muita
sensibilidade ao ferro a opção melhor é
a polimaltose se você não tem muita Sens
ilidade O sulfato ferroso ou fumarato
ferroso são opções
melhores
e pergunta da Aliane ex nicotinato
inositol junto com Colina podem prevenir
aterosclerose sim Podem sim porque o
exic dinato
inositol vai ajudar a baixar o LDL
aumentar o HDL também ajuda a baixar os
triglicérides tá e a colina
ela ajuda na função hepática e na função
cerebral Então os dois juntos seria uma
interessante combinação para ajudar a
reduzir a
aterosclerose e a colina também pode
ajudar um pouquinho a aumentar o HDL
colesterol
a baixo di cortisol
alto
depende numa
pessoa relativamente saudável sim AC H
baixo poderia indicar cortisol alto pelo
mecanismo de de
feedback ok porém existem causas tá de
por exemplo acth baixo e cortisol alto
que não seja por só pro biofeedback por
exemplo pessoa que tem síndrome de
cushing
ela vai ter o cortisol alto por seja
porque ela tá tomando corticosteroide ou
porque ela tem um tumor que produz o
cortisol e o acth vai baixar como
resposta a esse tumor isso pode
acontecer também com pessoas estão
estressadas não t um tumor tá agora pode
acontecer de ter
acth baixo e cortisol
baixo isso ocorre quando H deficiência
na produção de acth pela hipófise ou
seja uma deficiência de produção de acth
pela própria
hipótese desculpa
hipófise resultando então em baixos
níveis de cortisol então aí o cortisol
tá baixo porque o ath não tá funcionando
não tá estimulando adrenal Então essa é
uma causa também desse
problema outra situação também você pode
ter uma supressão prolongada do
hipotálamo hipófise adrenal isso pode
levar a baixo níveis de cth e cortisol
após a retirada dos
corticoides existe também a situação de
act alto e cortisol
alto se você tiver uma adoma hipofisário
que produz a cth ela
pode causar também um aumento do
cortisol porque você tá produzindo
demais então então tem várias situações
aqui tá então isso aí é uma coisa que
tem que ser analisado pelo
médico mais uma
pergunta Eliane endol TR cinol ou jein
qual seria mais eficiente o jein
geralmente é mais eficiente mas é mais
caro
tá então se você não tem nenhum tipo
de restrição financeira use o jein Tá
agora você pode associar o o Idol 3
cinol com jein para reduzir o custo
tá o din ele é um produto da
decomposição do endol trinol ele é
formado no estômago a partir da
degradação do endol escabin pelo ácido
Ok então se a pessoa tiver pouco ácido
no estômago provavelmente ela vai ter
dificuldade de converter o end escabin
no din Então se puder escolher use o din
isoladamente Ou use uma combinação de
Din com end escabin end escabin sozinho
pode ser arriscado porque essa pessoa
pode não converter no
estômago bem pessoal já estamos com uma
hora de Live tá eu acho que eu não vou
responder mais dúvidas ao vivo não
tá deixa eu tentar responder rapidamente
essas perguntas
aqui sim tem quefir de leite de coco e
tem quefir de leite de vaca são dois
Kefir diferentes
tá a o leite let sim é uma marca boa de
casina 2 tá
e o fato de ser pauster isado vai
reduzir substâncias bioativas né do
leite né Mas por outro lado torna ele
mais seguro para consumo então é
um por um lado é bom por outro lado é
ruim mas eu acho que é difícil você
achar um leite casina 2 que não é pastor
usado
Eliseu se tornar um bicker é uma boa
ideia depende Eliseu se você for um cara
extremamente inteligente estudioso pode
ser uma boa ideia se você eh não
consegue estudar de maneira eficaz
eficiente e não consegue entender
direito que você tá estudando pode ser
uma má
ideia isso aqui Eu já
respondi bom aqui a Estela tá dando
depoimento nós fizemos protocolo do
andras murit semana passada minha filha
faz a cada 4 meses excessão as cólicas
então tem benefício nesse protocolo Eu
só não acredito que o que sai seja
cálculos biliares não viu Stela mas eu
não tenho nada contra quem faça não eu
já falei agora há pouco que muitas
pessoas que fazem se sentem bem mas eu
já encontrei pessoas que sentem mal
fazendo
também o pessoal tá parece que concorda
comigo sobre o Fernando Lemos
eh Geralmente quem usa o al ring Eliseu
vai querer também ver
os resultados ali dos parâmetros do
software né Não entendi bem essa sua
pergunta não se a pessoa tá usando aora
ring ela vai querer saber se né os os
parâmetros lá né as as métricas né
sim é verdade Carlos eu cheguei a fazer
um vídeo contestando algumas coisas
assim você tem
razão concordo Carlos Eu acho que ele é
um pouco assim digamos assim oportunista
nesse ponto
aí olha novamente ele pode ser um
excelente coloproctologista tá não tô
julgando ele nem como profissional nem
como digamos assim parte humana que eu
não conheço ele eu tô só julgando ele
como youtuber
tá concordo com essa visão sua
Eliseu novamente o material explicando
sobre o titânio lá do hidrogenador tá no
grupo tá
um banho frio de 5 minutos à noite
expulsa toda a poluição eletromagnética
do corpo Creio que não Eliseu onde é que
você viu
isso não não acho que não tem nada a ver
banho frio com radição
eletromagnética sim existe uma relação
entre desuso e tamanho sim tá Eliseu
isso isso é não é fantasia não isso pode
acontecer Lógico que ele não vai sumir
só vai diminuir um pouco né em estado
ereto bem Já respondi todas as perguntas
pessoal Muito obrigado aí pela audiência
de vocês eu vou encerrar senão ninguém
aguenta assistir o vídeo depois mais de
uma hora de
duração nós nos vemos na semana que vem
um grande abraço um beijo no coração de
vocês tchau
tchau m